[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
14 octobre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission vous le
savez pour revenir sur l'actualité de la
semaine voici les titres elle les élus
du conseil départemental sur unis c'est
ce matin ils ont voté plusieurs projets
jeux olympiques de 2024 à paris futur
tram 13 express point complet à suivre
dans cette édition 1 durant cette
émission julien le cam responsable
régional adjoint du syndicat de police
alliance sera notre invité fil rouge
avec lui nous reviendrons évidemment sur
l'agression il ya quelques jours de
plusieurs policiers dans l'essonne nous
évoquerons aussi la situation sur notre
département et puis bien sûr le reste de
l'actualité avec françois de ligne et le
maire ps de guyancourt qui a annoncé sa
démission en début de semaine ou encore
le témoignage d'un astronaute français à
l'estaca mais on ouvre ce journal avec
les élus du conseil départemental qui se
sont retrouvés ce matin en séance ils
ont évoqué et voté plusieurs sujets et
notamment le lancement des travaux
préparatoires pour le tram 13 express ou
le soutien à la candidature de paris
pour les jeux olympiques 2024 les
précisions avec michael et demi d'euros
une séance importantes sont le président
du département pierre betty les
conseillers départementaux se réunissent
ce matin versailles à l'ordre du jour la
dissolution de l'eau pied voit l'un des
plus gros bailleurs sociaux
d'ile-de-france avec cinquante mille
logements dont 17500 dans les yvelines
une décision imposée par la loi lure sur
l'urbanisme qui prévoit le démantèlement
de la structure ce qui fera tenir dans
cette affaire c'est que rien ne changera
pour les locataires puisque ignorons ils
auront à nouveau quittancement mais ça
sera le même niveau donc il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de loyer et rien ne
changera pour les personnels sinon que
les personnels du siège déménageront
mais pour le reste les personnels de
proximité resteront et les personnels du
siège durera pas de licenciements au
centre des débats également le
financement des travaux préparatoires de
l'opération tram 13 express la désormais
ex tangentielle ouest reliant le rer a
de saint-germain-en-laye au rer c de
saint-cyr-l'ecole coup au total des
travaux à 6 millions d'euros ces
infrastructures de transports en commun
sont dans notre esprit complémentaire
de toutes les autres infrastructures de
transport pour à la fois améliorer notre
cadre de vie pouvoir se déplacer est
agréable ne plus être pollué par les
embouteillages et tout aussi agréable
donc c'est c'est dans cette logique des
mobilités nouvelle que s'inscrit le
département enfin le conseil
départemental des yvelines a également
voté une approbation du soutien
financier à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros afin d'aménager la colline
d'elancourt en vue des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques 2024 le site qui
culmine à 3 131 mètres d'altitude a été
retenue pour accueillir les compétitions
de vtt hommes et femmes donc oui nous
espérons que paris 2024 soit une réalité
nous l'espérons vraiment de tout coeur
et nous prendrons notre part dans cet
effort donc je dois dire qu'il est
raisonnable se rendent pas des jeux
olympiques avec des dépenses que la
france hélas n'est plus capable de
supporter la prochaine séance du conseil
départemental sera organisée le 25
novembre prochain
[Musique]
et pour aborder l'actualité de la
semaine nous a rejoints sur notre
plateau julien le cam secrétaire
régional adjoint du syndicat de police
alliance bonsoir on va débuter bien sûr
cet entretien avec vous et cette
actualité malheureuse qui concerne 4 de
votre collègue quatre de vos collègues
dans l'essonne quatre agents étaient
attaqués il ya maintenant une semaine
environ alors qu'il surveillait une
caméra de vidéosurveillance dans leur
véhicule plusieurs personnes leur ont
jeté alors des cocktails molotov
résultat quatre agents blessés dont 1
toujours dans un état très très grave
préoccupons quand on apprend une telle
nouvelle vous qui êtes agent de police
depuis une heure maintenant de
nombreuses années comment comment on
réagit concrètement est-ce qu'on est on
est prêt à encaisser ce type de
nouvelles avec le temps ou alors c'est
toujours aussi difficile on s'habitue
jamais c'est vrai que c'est avec
beaucoup d froid qu'on a appris
justement la tentative d'assassinât dont
ont été victimes nos quatre collègues le
week-end dernier effectivement c on ne
peut pas habituel genre d'événements
tragiques pur hasard du calendrier la
même semaine c'est à dire cette semaine
quelques jours après cette attaque des
chiffres sont sortis concernant le
nombre de policiers blessés en france
l'an passé le chiffre est et précis 2388
policiers blessés en 2015 soit plus de
1000 par mois ce sont des chiffres qui
sont très légèrement en baisse par
rapport à 2014 mais qui reste conséquent
est ce que vous diriez que la voie de la
violence envers la police c'est aussi
quelque chose qui c'est qui s'est
augmentée qui c'est on va dire
normalisées avec le temps en plus de la
violence on va dire classique dû à votre
métier qui est à la base dangereux non
malheureusement comme nous l'a vite
laissé violence là se banalise si vous
voulez on peut on assiste à un véritable
abandon de la police de la part de la
justice
qui effectivement il n'y a aucune
réponse pénale ferme face à aux
délinquants
c'est vrai que les violences ont été
banalisés parce qu'il n'y a pas de
réponses fermes et durs de la part la
justice et sa selon vous c'est depuis on
va dire quelques années quelques mois ou
alors ça remonte déjà c'est un phénomène
qui a déjà quinze ou vingt ans est ce
que vous arrivez à situer à peu près
quand est ce que la situation s'est
vraiment dégradée dans le temps je peux
pas vous dire simplement de ta leur
voyage était au commissariat de plaisir
j'ai assisté à une scène qui veut tout
dire j'étais à l'intérieur du
commissariat il ya mes collègues qui
devait transporter trois personnes au
palais de justice pour être prendre
présenté à un magistrat donc ces 3
délinquants lorsqu'ils sont extraits de
leur cellule de garde à vue pour être
mis dans le camion discuter entre elles
et rigoler donc si oui notre justice
fait rigoler les délinquants donc c'est
tout un symbole mes collègues feront
face à ça tous les jours à ces formes de
provocation et effectivement c'est la
justice ne fait plus peur selon vous le
problème principal aujourd'hui la faute
de tout cela on va dire c'est la justice
mais du coup quelque part c'est l'état
puisque c'est l'état qui finance la wii
effectivement
je pense que s'il y avait le
rétablissement des peines planchers et
des réponses fermes de la part de la
justice il faut que la peur change de
camp 1 c'est vrai que quand voyez ces
individus qui n'hésite pas à attaquer
nos collègues alors que ces derniers
gardent une caméra de vidéosurveillance
il faut que ces jeunes ces délinquants
et peur de s'en prendre à des policiers
là ce n'est pas le cas de nombreux
policiers expriment très généralement et
ça c'est depuis de nombreuses années un
sentiment d'abandon qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'ils expriment
comment vous exprimer ce sentiment
d'abandon à travers quels types comment
comment comment comme on en vient à se
sentir abandonné aujourd'hui au sein de
la police et à travers du manque de
matériel à travers quoi vous l'avez
voilà le manque de matériel le manque le
manque d'effectifs depuis une dizaine
d'années sur le département on voit que
les effectifs de police diminuent
dangereusement 1 actuellement des
petites structures de police sont fermés
sur le département effectivement quand
vous voyez les effectifs de votre
commissariat diminué d'année en année
les moyens diminuent également c'est
vrai que ce sont pas forcément des
gestes qu'on attende la par nos élus nos
politiques on attend des moyens vous
disiez avant cet entretien en l'espace
de dix ans le département des yvelines a
perdu à peu près 300 fonctionnaires de
police et ça c'est ça actuellement on
est en train de fermer des commissariats
a envoyé le commissariat de vélizy va
être fermé par manque d'effectif
il ya une restructuration des services
qui a été effectué il ya trois ans par
manque d'effectif donc on a tout
simplement regrouper les effectifs dans
des agglomérations
laissant des commissariats à l'abandon
sur le département après ce qui s'est
passé dans l'essonne votre votre
syndicat a demandé à faire une grève aux
policiers de faire une grève du zèle de
c'est à dire qu'en gros vous intervenez
uniquement en cas d'urgence en cas de
besoin on va dire important est ce que
vous soutenez ce type d'opération est ce
que c'est pas aussi prendre en otage
malheureusement aussi un peu la
population avec sont inopérants
justement non le service minimum qui a
été donc c'est un appel de notre
syndicat alliance police nationale qui
effective du coup sur l'ensemble de la
france mais particulièrement on va dire
en ile de france
le mouvement est très suivi en ile de
france on se sent tous concernés par
l'agression effectivement donc c'est un
c'est un geste de compassion et de
soutien envers nos collègues c'est
service minimum c'est en fait
d'intervenir sur apple a évidemment les
collègues continueront d'assurer les
gens à bien l'eau contre ça ça va de soi
ça va de soirée par contre tout ce qui
est
verbalisation est prêt initial yvon
demande aux collègues justement
d'arrêter d'instaurer un rapport de
force avec nos politiques pour montrer
le ras-le-bol de la profession c'est
devenu aujourd'hui votre seul moyen
d'action pour vous faire entendre auprès
de ohb à greta auprès des décideurs
politiques exactement on attend des
gestes forts de nos de nos politiques on
attend de l'aide c'est vrai que là quand
on voit
nos politiques qui ce qui se présente
aux présidentielles on attend de leur
part des mots forts et justement
se décompose tous en tout cas à droite
aujourd'hui c'était le premier débat des
primaires très récemment ils proposent
tous une augmentation des effectifs une
nouvelle hausse enfin une hausse des
effectifs de policiers c'est de nature à
vous rassurer ça pour l'avenir alors les
effectifs ne font pas tout on est
effectivement on attendait renfort en
effectifs mais par exemple on nous nous
attendons également une réforme delà de
la légitime défense quand on voit nous
on demande à ce que nos collègues
puissent réagir en cas de danger
immédiat effectivement on ne peut pas
tolérer que nos
mes collègues policiers et le mêmes
droits qu'un citoyen lambda pour se
défendre il doit pouvoir réagir avec son
arme en cas de danger immédiat ce qui
s'est passé il ya une semaine dans
l'essonne est ce que concrètement ça
pourrait arriver dans les yvelines est
ce qu'il ya des endroits où concrètement
il ya une détestation de la police
important on le voit un renforcement
nommé des quartiers ou des biens non
mais on le voit là depuis une semaine
mes collègues sur mantes la jolie sont
régulièrement caillassé on a vu des tags
antipolis le là il ya quelques jours
après les événements dans le 91 et
malheureusement ce genre d'événement
pourrait arriver sur le 78
malheureusement les évènements trappe il
ya quelques quelques temps il ya trois
ans il ya deux ans et demi un sur le
département il y avait une telle
violence que effectivement ça pourrait
arriver sur département malheureusement
julien lecat me rester avec nous on va
revenir sur cette actualité tragique et
voir notamment ce qui est possible de
faire selon vous pour inverser la
tendance mais d'actualité départemental
cette semaine c'était aussi la démission
surprise de françois de ligne et le
maire socialiste de guyancourt depuis
2002 il a indiqué vouloir passer le
relais il conservera tout de même c'est
fonctions de conseiller municipal et
conseiller communautaire au sein de
l'agglomération retour sur un parcours
remarqué par un volontarisme économique
et une proximité avec les habitants avec
patrick jacques de dixmude et alors
languir
deux ans et demi après sa réélection
françois de ligne et jette l'épongé le
maire ps de guyancourt n'a donné pour
expliquer sa démission d'autres raisons
que celles de passer le relais à temps
il ya une décision de passage de relais
et pourquoi maintenant parce que avec
d'état d'esprit que j'indiquais c'est à
dire celui
d'une préparation de l'avenir je sais
que c'est le bon moment parce qu'on va
pouvoir travailler en continuité
l'ancien instituteur mer depuis 2002
répète ainsi l'histoire son prédécesseur
à la mairie de guyancourt roland nadeau
c'était en effet lui aussi démis de ses
fonctions en cours de mandat c'est un
message aussi de poursuites puisque
françois de ligne continue j'en reste
encore un petit peu ici je prends un peu
de champ et b ma ville c'est ma vie de
son côté l'opposition havok l'usure dont
se serait plaint en privé françois de
lignées mais aussi l'existence de
conflits internes à sa majorité
guyancourt pour tous des propos que
l'intéressé dément chez lui là quelqu'un
de l'opposition parlant d' usure
bon on verra parce que moi je serai dans
le conseil jusqu'à 2020 il verra si si
on a une équipe usée élu depuis 1989
françois de ligne et a gagné la
réputation d'homme accessible grâce
notamment à son dispositif allô monsieur
le maire mais c'est surtout son bilan
économique que l'on retiendra surfant
sur l'attractivité de son territoire il
a su convaincre de grandes entreprises
d'y investir nous sommes une ville qui
atteint sa maturité qui est encore en
dynamique et qu'un projet qui placera
demain hui en cours comme étant toujours
la locomotive même pas de saint quentin
en yvelines plus largement du bassin de
vie c'est marie-christine le tarnec 60
ans première adjointe en charge de
l'éducation de la jeunesse et des
finances qui devrait lui succéder avant
la fin de l'année une passation de
pouvoir bien orchestrée qui permettent à
l'équipe municipale de se projeter
au-delà de 2020 mais une question
subsiste sera ce suffisant pour barrer
le passage à la droite
l'actualité cette semaine c'est aussi de
l'économie avec la première édition du
sky a business cd qui se tenait ce jeudi
l'objectif était simple permettre aux
tpe et pme de rencontrer les grands
entreprises bordas rendez-vous un rendez
vous fixé au vélodrome national avec 400
entreprises présentes écoutez à ce
propos jean michel fourgous vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines au micro de
haussmann vendeurs des
scellés grosse boîte aussi nous disent
qu'elles ont tellement de demandes
qu'elles ont du mal à les gérer alors
que là elle voit tout de suite plu
client le client enfin le fournisseur
pardon il est il et voilà il se présente
pas beaucoup plus brièvement fin bien
entendu c'est un activateur dans des
conditions de qualité vous avez vu les
conditions et même un wigan un état
d'esprit de champion on met en tout cas
les meilleures conditions pour qu'ils se
connaissent certains dorment souvent des
grosses en 2010 mais à bon je vais
découvrir un camion une petite pme aaa à
500 mètres et je travaille avec une pme
à 1000 kilomètres c'est vrai que comment
ça se fait que vous n'avez pas dire
c'est donc on est là on est décidé de
donner cet événement aussi pour ça pour
que tout le monde se connaisse beaucoup
mieux il ya d'autres événements dire
qu'ils vont voir le jour à saint quentin
pour bien voilà les petits les gros en
tout cas se connaissent plus travaillent
plus ensemble les rencontres de la
sécurité se déroule cette semaine dans
les yvelines jusqu'à samedi une semaine
spéciale qui permet de découvrir celles
et ceux qui assurent notre sécurité au
quotidien chaque année 300 mille
personnes participent à l'événement
partout en france reportage dans les
yvelines avec un orlandi
un chien après un sachet de drogue une
interpellation à cheval le sauvetage
d'une conductrice pour cette nouvelle
édition des rencontres de la sécurité
une vingtaine de policiers gendarmes et
pompiers se sont pliés au jeu de la
démonstration mais pas seulement ils ont
aussi tenu à expliquer étape par étape
chaque opération
on y vit du groupe diminuent en descend
jamais un cheval vous voyez la collecte
ou
une centaine d'élèves et quelques
dizaines de passants ont assisté captivé
aux exercices ce qui n'a pas manqué de
réveiller chez certains leur fibre
patriotique c'est une immense à la fois
fierté voilà que notre pays soit
performant dans toutes ses actions et en
même temps oui une immense admiration
pour que ces hommes et ces femmes qui
sont vraiment en nos services
pourtant les relations entre les forces
de l'ordre et la population ont connu
des hauts et des bas ces derniers mois
la manifestation intervient dans un
contexte tendu après l'attaqué des
policiers dans l'essonne
mais selon un récent sondage 82 % des
français gardent une bonne opinion de la
police le but des démonstrations c'est
de rapprocher la population des
gendarmes des policiers des pompiers à
travers des commandes des opérations
dynamique ce qui permet aussi à la
population de se rendre compte un petit
peu des différentes facettes de notre
métier nul doute que la manifestation
aura suscité des vocations s'engager
c'est avant tout faire preuve de courage
et de dévouement c'est en tout cas le
message clair qu'ont voulu faire passer
les organisateurs de cette journée
julien le cas mais ce que ce type
d'opération comme on vient de le voir
dans le reportage est ce que c'est bon
pour rapprocher on va dire les gens et
la police parfois les relations sont
tendues surtout avec vous le disais les
délinquants mais là c'est normal mais
parfois la police et une mauvaise image
à tort est ce que c'est bon de faire ce
type d'opération pour vous rapprocher
des citoyens lambda de monsieur et
madame tout le monde oui oui vous pouvez
on l'a vu un sur le reportage ça permet
de montrer aussi les difficultés
voilà gérer votre métier voilà un tabou
au soit fait interpeller avec les les
les collègues de la brée dit avec les
chevaux les interventions de notre
brigade canine ça peut peut-être faire
oui découvrir des vocations aux jeunes
qui viennent voir mes collègues
travailler oui devant la préfecture ça
globalement est ce que vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un manque de
proximité tout de même entre la police
et les citoyens
pas forcément vous l'avez dit 1 82% des
des gens ont une bonne opinion de la
police 1 c'est vrai que malheureusement
on a pu les les effectifs de l'époque ya
eu des fermetures de bureaux de police
moins de fonctionnaires dehors et
peut-être moins de temps du coup pour
faire cette police de proximité mais je
pense quand même que les que les gens
ont une bonne opinion de la police fait
après l'agression des quatre agents dans
l'essonne la semaine passée les
syndicats de police ont demandé à ce que
les policiers donc vous même vous
reveniez à votre coeur de métier
concrètement quelles missions vous
voudriez absolument faire demain et ne
plus faire alors on parle de tâches
induit un c'est vrai que nous notre
syndicat alliance police nationale
demande à ce que le policier soit
recentrée au coeur de son métier c'est à
dire la sécurité sur la voie publique 1
malheureusement beaucoup de nombreux
collègues sur le département des
dizaines de collègues font des tâches
indues place et transfèrements de
détenus les cartes de détenus
hospitalisés
les gardes de personnalités de domiciles
de personnalités voilà les gardes de
commissariats vide effectivement c'est
d'oser pas d'émission on va dire
nécessaire en tout cas la seconde et on
va dire exactement où vous auriez plus
de patrouilles sur le terrain quand vous
perdez à versailles à chaque début de
vacation douzaine de fonctionnaires qui
vont sur des points fixes c'est autant
de fonctionnaires en moins pour
sécuriser la voie publique et selon vous
qui pourrait du coup faire ce type de
mission là dont vous parlez est ce que
ça peut être la police municipale est ce
qu il faut renforcer le rôle de la
police municipale par exemple n'ont pas
forcément je pense plutôt que par
exemple pour les gardes de détenus
hospitalisés
c'est un c'est une mission qui est
dévolue à
l'administration pénitentiaire
je pense que voilà ou deux peut être
privatisée
les gardes de peut-être certaines
personnalités 1 pour gagner des agents
armés et formés sur le terrain pour
aider les gens et sécuriser les sites
sensibles on l'a évoqué un peu tout et
là on va revenir dessus mais qu'est ce
qui vous manque principalement
aujourd'hui par exemple après ce qui
s'est passé dans l'essonne manuel valls
et bernard cazeneuve ont annoncé l'envoi
de renforts dans le département sans
sans agent en plus et aussi des des
nouveaux dispositifs anti anti anti
caillassage c'est positif ça ou alors
vous dites à chaque fois c'est la même
chose et finalement ça il se passe
toujours aussi la même chose lorsque
effectivement on attend on attendait
atteint pas pas forcément que des
paroles en la profession en a ras le bol
d'entendre justement ces récupérations
un peu politique avec de belles phrases
nous ce qu'on sait sont fonctionnaires
ils vont les trouver où ils vont les
enlever du 78 ils vont les ont enlevés
de paris de la petite couronne pour
aller renforcer les collègues du 4 au 11
mai on renforce pas globalement les
effectifs c'est on le retire quelque
part pour les mettre par là donc je n'en
doute pas que mes collègues du 4 ans ont
besoin d'effectifs supplémentaires mais
on le voit j'ai déjà que certains
collègues du 78 qui ont été appelés à
renforcer le 91 donc en fin de compte on
va nous enlever des effectifs dans le 78
pour aller
on réagit à l'actualité si vous êtes
plus de la communication voilà après
l'attentât de nice du mois de juillet
françois hollande a relancé l'idée des
réservistes pour appuyer les forces de
l'ordre dans leur mission la fameuse
garde nationale a été lancé
officiellement cette semaine quel regard
vous portez sur ce nouvel outil c'est
cetc positive pour vous alors ça doit
juste être une solution finale et a
rarement utilisée je pense que c'est une
solution ponctuelle on ne peut pas
pérenniser une telle une telle pratique
c'est vrai que nous on veut des
effectifs jeunes formés c'est vrai que
nos réservistes
palier un manque d'effectif nommé ne
sont pas la solution c'est vrai que
c'est toujours bien d'avoir des anciens
qui ont fait 30 ans de police venir
aider les jeunes mais si vous laissez
pas
de mesurettes je penserai ça va faire
bientôt un an que l'état d'urgence a été
décrété en france si on ajoute ça au
plan vigipirate
concrètement vous avez plus aujourd'hui
les moyens d'assurer vos missions vous
êtes à flux tendu là on est sûr on va
dire at-elle rouge prêt à basculer du
côté non mais il ya une superposition
des missions c'est vrai que si vous
voulez s'ajoute à ça les événements
sportifs on a pu voir leurs euros la
coop 21 avant c'est vrai que les
collègues sont épuisés fatigué de cette
superposition des missions on a besoin
de renfort d'effectifs urgemment sur le
département on en revient à l'actualité
de la semaine maintenant avec une
réunion d'information sur le don du sang
de plaquettes et d'organes qui était
organisée à saint quentin en yvelines au
théâtre de saint quentin en yvelines en
partenariat avec la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines et
l'institut de promotion de la santé une
soirée pour tenter de répondre aux
questions sur les démarches à suivre ou
encore les besoins un reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude
faire connaître le dos médical c'était
l'objectif de ces intervenants de la
santé ce mardi 11 octobre au théâtre de
saint quentin en yvelines organisée en
partenariat avec la caisse primaire
d'assurance-maladie daisy weideli ps
l'institut de promotion de la santé la
réunion d'information était centrée sur
le don du sang de plaquettes et
d'organes je crois qu'il faut c'est
comme une porte il faut il faut
l'apprécier un peu plus facilement et et
s'engouffrer dedans
c'est donc effectivement faire connaître
des sites fixes qui sont les nôtres
parce qu'on a beaucoup plus de mal pour
recruter les donneurs c'est important de
faire connaître
au public le la loi et les problèmes que
nous rencontrons aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines le don d'organes est effectué
dans les hôpitaux de poissy saint
germain en laye de versailles la réunion
d'information a permis de clarifier la
loi sur ce sujet méconnu du grand public
la loi dit que nous sommes tous des
donneurs présumés et donc si on est
opposé au don d'organes aux dons issus
de son vivant il faut vraiment le dire
on peut aussi s'inscrire sur le registre
national des refus là aussi on est pour
on peut prendre une carte mais
légalement ça n'a pas de valeur donc le
plus important c'est vraiment on entend
parler à ses proches à sa famille parce
que c'est vers eux qu on se tournera si
vous arrive quelque chose pour savoir si
vous était donné à rouen en france 6000
et greffes d'organes sont effectués
chaque année pour environ 20000
personnes qui sont sur liste d'attenté
les donneurs peuvent effectuer un don
sans limite d'âge
et si votre chien devenez écolo l'idée
peut paraître étrange au premier abord
mais c'est le cas d'elliot le labrador
de gildas un habitant de montigny son
animal de compagnie ramasse depuis cinq
ans tous les détritus qu'il trouve
pendant ces balades une passion qui lui
est venue naturellement et qui
impressionne c'est bien normal ses
voisins nous avons rencontré le maître
et le chien écolo reportage de miquel et
demi d'euros et de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
ramasser les déchets dans la rue une
passion pour elia depuis ses deux ans du
haut de ses quatre pattes ce labrador
traque les détritus lors de ses balades
quotidiennes
c'est venu des armes en tant qu il a
commencé par une bouteille il ya
quelques années en plus ça a continué en
s'aggravant si on peut dire s'aggrave en
ramassant plus de choses et pour lui
c'est une passion maintenant tous les
jours de ramasser le maximum de choses
et de les ramener
bouteilles en plastique emballages pizza
ou paquets de cigarettes vides tant
qu'il peut attraper elliott récupère
tous et pas question d'abandonner son
trésor sur le chemin est un rituel il va
s'arrêter normalement devant le
conteneur et devant le contenir il va
tout lâcher là je peux vous montrer
qu'il lâchera pas je peux toujours et
s'étirer en aucune façon il a trois
choses qui contribuent et fait
qu'arriver à la maison qui va accepter
tout lâcher pour avoir
un comportement écologique qui attise la
curiosité à 7 ans l'animal est devenu
une star dans le quartier
sachez intelligent à notre l'autre notre
chien là du voisin je pense que c'est
une bonne chose mais bon c'est dommage
que des gens il ya quelque chose comme
ça dans la rue c'est pas bien elliott il
sera content un chien quand même que les
gens y font n'importe quoi voir tous les
jours elliott accompagne également son
mettre au travail dans le cadre de la
police de l'eau cette ruche n'a pas fini
de nettoyer nos amis
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci
julien le cam de nous avoir accompagnés
pendant cette émission je rappelle que
vous êtes le secrétaire régional adjoint
du syndicat de police alliance merci à
vous aussi de nous avoir suivis bon
week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]